[Musique]
brard berger bonjour et bienvenue à
montigny-le-bretonneux hope to you pour
votre café politique au cours du
prochain quart d'heure nous allons
parler de votre parcours votre parcours
en politique et il est assez conséquent
même si vous n'avez que 32 ans député de
la 10h31 faisait un petit peu vieilli
député de la 10e circonscription des
yvelines sous l'étiquette république en
marche
un porte-parole du groupe également à
l'assemblée conseillère municipale
d'opposition à magny les hameaux
la conseillère communautaire aussi à
saint quentin en yvelines depuis 2014 à
votre carrière a véritablement débuté à
16 ans vous vous êtes engagé c'était un
engagement contre le front national
c'est ça qui a déclenché l'engagement
politique pour vous oui c'est ça qui
déclenche son engagement politique parce
que le 21 avril 2002 c'est la première
fois que le front national au second
tour d'une élection présidentielle ont
scié malheureusement presque habitués
aujourd'hui mais à l'époque ça provoque
quand même une forme de sidération celle
ensemble en fait des français qui
considèrent ça comme quelque chose de
totalement anormal risque est dangereux
puis dans le même temps il y à la
création d'un nouveau parti politique
qui était à l'époque l'ump d'alain juppé
et qui réunissait l'ensemble des forces
de la droite du centre et des libéraux
est aujourd'hui le front national reste
une menace pour front national reste une
menace
évidemment l'extrême droite est une
menace et
même si marine le pen a essayé de le
moderniser d'en changer d'image
déjà on sait plus franchement quels sont
les positionnements du front national
sur un certain nombre de sujets par
contre on sait quels sont les
fondamentaux qui restent du front
national et ses des fondamentaux qu'il
faut combattre cet état d'esprit engagé
et militant dès l'âge de 16 ans est ce
que vous l'avez hérité de vos parents
est ce qu'on parlait politique à la
maison on parlait beaucoup politique à
la maison même si eux mêmes n'ont jamais
été comme on dit encarté au membre d'un
parti politique mais c'est vrai que le
débat a toujours été quelques chose
d'assez entente dans nos repas de
famille soit petite famille parce que je
suis fille unique mais ça a toujours été
très très animée et puis je pense que ça
éveille aussi à nos consciences
citoyennes politique et ça facilite
l'engagement que ce soit quelque chose
de naturel de parler politique à la
maison et beaucoup de familles où il
faut pas en parler mais c'est tabou de
parler politique non au contraire
c'était quelque chose de naturel vous
auriez pu hériter d'un autre talon je
fais une parenthèse avec la politique
mais c'est plus le talent artistique qui
aurait plus prévaloir à la maison
puisque votre mère et votre père sont
tous les deux acteurs doubleur de série
à télévision pour votre pour votre mère
et puis votre père c'est notamment la
voix française de sylvester stallone
donc on parlait parlait de ça aussi à la
maison ce talent artistique e set
peut-être que vous auriez aimé avoir au
set suivant vraiment avoir une vocation
pour le fart ceux des métiers qui sont
extrêmement exigeants extrêmement
aléatoire mes deux parents sont
comédiens depuis toujours pour mon père
ma mère après un autre parcours tout
début de sa vie professionnelle mais
c'est une vocation qu'on a ou qu'on a
pas et moi j'ai à la fois j'ai beaucoup
de respect et d'admiration pour
évidemment leur parcours et pour ceux
qui font ce choix là mais moi je aucun
moment où vous avez fait du théâtre
j'aurais
des métiers que j'adorerais faire quand
même scénariste ou autre avantage c'est
que comme faire la politique justement
c'est pas un métier qu'on foute à ça
toute sa vie il aura peut-être d'autres
après alors on en revient à la politique
cet engagement militant certes il est né
à à ce moment où anglais du second tour
de l'élection présidentielle avec
l'arrivée du front national mais
néanmoins au delà de l'engagement
militant il ya l'engagement
véritablement politique et vous êtes
devenu responsable des jeunes populaires
des yvelines et ça c'était un travail à
plein temps alors un travail à plein
temps en même temps j'avais la chance de
faire mes études donc j'essayais quand
même de conduire les deux étaient à ce
moment là vous êtes jamais dit je
rentrais en politique à ce moment là et
peut-être que du coup je vais engager
une carrière politique
non c'était pas le but le but c'était
d'avoir un vrai engagement politique est
en effet que cet engagement politique ne
cesse pas c'est à dire c'est pas la même
chose d'en faire un métier est de
considérer qu' il faut qu'ils aient des
étapes un peu obligé que ça va durer 40
ans de votre vie si la question c'est
est-ce que l'engagement politique
continuera même si demain je suis plus
élu oui parce que ça ça n'a rien à voir
avec le fait d'en vivre
quand j'étais responsable des jeunes
évidemment j'en faisais pas j'étais pas
rémunérés pour ça j'étais étudiante à
côté et on a des millions de français
qui s'engage dans la vie associative et
dans la vie politique et qui veulent pas
forcément pour autant chercher à avoir
une place on va dire et c'est un peu
sale travers qu'on a eu parfois en
politique c'est de vouloir conquérir des
places avant que de vouloir avoir cet
engagement qui est un engagement sincère
militant comment ça a été perçu par
votre famille manière très naturelle
j'aurais pu avoir
l'engagement que je voulais sauf si
j'avais choisi évidemment le front
national encore je sors été plus
compliquée avec la famille ça sera un
match compliqué sans histoire est une
rupture par jeu c'est clairement ce que
mon père m'avait dit quand vous savez
que ça faisait longtemps que je voulais
m'engager etc
il lui fera ce que tu veux mais sitôt
fnj sera plus ma fille pas donc après
j'ai été élevé dans certaines valeurs
ils sont fiers de vos combats on parle
de valeurs il ya eu un engagement très
fort pour vous aussi c'était celui en
faveur du mariage pour tous par exemple
qui a aussi commencé à fissurer votre
relation est votre formation politique
ils sont fiers de vos combats de vos
engagements je sais pas s'il y ont
toujours été je sais qu'ils sont plus à
l'aise avec la famille politique à
laquelle j'appartiens aujourd'hui que
celle à laquelle j'ai pu appartenir même
s'ils n'ont jamais reprocher
voilà n'ai jamais eu de reproche par
rapport au positionnement aux positions
que je pouvais prendre
je pense qu'ils sont fiers que je fasse
quelque chose qui me correspond que ce
soit un endroit qui me correspond et
surtout que j'ai toujours assumé mes
prises de position quand bien même cela
ne pouvait me mettre en difficulté à
l'époque en effet à l'ump n'était pas
très nombreux à être en faveur du
mariage pour tous
et aujourd'hui les mêmes qui
manifestaient les mêmes qui disaient il
faut des mariés les couples homosexuels
10 mais évidemment la droite ne
reviendra jamais sur ce qui est devenu
un et qui ont finalement on était peu
nombreux à l'époque
mais ils ont rejoint notre position
c'était le début de la rupture avec la
droite ump l'est républicain qu'est ce
qui a marqué définitivement la cassure
avec votre ancienne famille politique
la cassure s'est alors elle commence
vraiment avec ça ce que j'ai pas compris
c'est qu'on puisse appeler à manifester
contre les droits des autres c'est
quelque chose qui intellectuellement
nettement m'échappe de manifester contre
les droits des autres là où ça ne retire
rien à ceux qui les ont déjà
donc il ya eu ça et puis après c'est
vraiment l'élection de françois fillon à
la primaire de la droite et du centre
qui l'a définitivement qui avait soutenu
alain juppé pendant deux ans la campagne
d'alain juppé je suis toujours proche de
lui on continue à se voir quelqu'un qui
se rapproche aussi de la république en
marche pour je pense qu'à une communauté
de valeurs et d'idées la meilleure
traduction c'est qu edouard philippe qui
aujourd'hui premier ministre des modèles
macron était l'un des plus proches si ce
n'est le plus proche d'alain juppé
pendant ces quinze vingt dernières
années donc oui elle communauté de
valeurs notamment sur les questions
européennes puisque c'est là dessus que
qu'alain juppé s'est positionné aussi
récemment on vous a souvent reproché le
fait d'avoir soutenu des personnalités
très différentes en politique j'aimerais
tout de même qu'on y revient d'un petit
peu valérie pécresse lors des élections
régionales de 2010 en ile de france
nicolas sarkozy pour la présidentielle
de 2012 françois fillon pour la
présidence de l'ump la même année et
puis la primaire de la droite avec alain
juppé puis ensuite emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui vous répondez quoi à vos
détracteurs lorsqu'on vous dit encore
vous avez quand même changé beaucoup de
candidats au fur et à mesure des années
tout simple c'est qu'à un moment de
votre vie vous vous êtes retrouvé dans
ces personnalités peut-être tout
simplement parce que la droite a changé
parce que le nicolas sarkozy que j'ai
soutenu en effet de 2007 à 2012 n'est
pas le même qu'en pendant la primaire de
la droite et du centre on en vient plus
qu'à parler des questions identitaires
et des menus halal à la cantine scolaire
et on voit aujourd'hui un laurent
wauquiez on se demande vraiment ce qui
le sépare des thèses souverainistes
identitaire porté par un certain nombre
de personnalités de l'extrême droite ou
de florian philippot avec son nouveau
mouvement no qu'est-ce qui vaut mieux
est ce qu'à un moment il vaut mieux
admettre qu'en effet par rapport aux
idées comporte bien il ya différentes
personnes qui peuvent les incarner
ou alors avoir tellement changer soi
même dit dès qu'on en vient à plus être
lisible sur ce qu'on a envie de dire aux
français si on peut parler de vos
mandats locaux également parce que magny
les hameaux vous siéger dans
l'opposition alors magny les hameaux qui
ne se situe pas dans la 10e
circonscription c'est un autre secteur
ça veut dire que par la suite vous allez
à quitter cette commune pour vous
recentrer sur la 10e circonscription du
côté de rambouillet moi j'ai pris un
engagement quand je me suis présenté en
2014 c'est d'aller à minima au bout du
mandat
c'était la première fois que je me
présentais sur mon nom c'était une belle
campagne exigeante où on a mis en place
aussi une équipe on a continué à la
construire on a commencé cette campagne
dès 2012 on a aujourd'hui en 2007 on a
construit quelque chose sur mesnil
amelot une autre vision aussi de ce que
doit être cette commune et moi j'ai
envie de continuer à travailler
évidemment je suis toujours présent que
je le peins conseil municipal je vis
toujours à magny les hameaux
donc c'est une commune qui laquelle je
suis très attaché
du simple fait du cumul des mandats je
pourrais pas être tête de liste aux
prochaines élections municipales ça la
question
par contre moi les gens ce qu'est la
mienne c'est d'être honnête et de tenir
l'engagement qui était le mien d'être
présente dans cette commune jusqu'à la
fin du mandat et après avec l'équipe qui
sera choisi
voir si c'est pertinent ou pas que je
continue à les accompagner le regard que
vous avez sur le travail mené par
emmanuel macron depuis son élection
je pense que ce qui importe le message
passe bien auprès de la population
il faut toujours peut-être faire encore
plus preuve de pédagogie expliquer ce
qu'on est en train de fermer ce qui est
une évidence et c'est d'ailleurs les
français quand ils sont consultés qu'ils
disent c'est qu'il note on fait ce qu'on
avait dit et ça ça change c'est à dire
il n'y a pas d'espèces d'agenda caché où
tout d'un coup on découvrira des
réformes qui n'avait pas été annoncée
j'aimerais vous faire réagir sur
beaucoup de sujets d'actualité ont pour
vous faire réagir mais néanmoins sur
celui ci est assez celui du harcèlement
sexuel la parole se libère
vous devez l'apprécier j'imagine parce
que vous-même mai 2016 vous avez dénoncé
des propos sexistes d'élus de la
majorité de la droite et du centre au
sein d'une séance de travail au conseil
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
vous n'avez pas souhaité donner le nom
des élus en question à l'époque déjà est
ce que vous le regrettez non je ne
regrette pas parce que ce qui est
important c'est qu'il ya une prise de
conscience sur le fait que
malheureusement le harcèlement sexuel
quand vous regardez dans votre entourage
collègues amis famille quasiment toutes
les femmes de votre entourage ont un
moment subi du harcèlement sexuel
harcèlement dans les transports
notamment en ile-de-france 100 % des
femmes disent que ça leur est déjà
arrivé harcèlement au travail etc donc
le simple fait déjà d'arriver à prendre
la parole est nécessaire et pour que les
femmes puissent prendre la parole
il faut encore que leur parole soit
entendue qu'elle soit respectée et c'est
pas toujours le cas parce que à chaque
fois que les femmes prennent la parole
sur ce sujet on les interpelle en disant
pourquoi ne s'exprime que maintenant
pourquoi ils ont attendu est-ce qu'elles
le feraient pas parce qu'ils ont envie
de se venger et maintenant les femmes
n'ont jamais un intérêt à s'exposer à
dire ce qui leur est arrivé
elles le font parce qu'à un moment elles
en ressentent le besoin la nécessité et
moi si je les fais à l'époque c'est
aussi parce qu'on était dans le contexte
de ce qu'on a appelé la ferme aux pins
où il y avait des femmes très courageuse
qui ont assumé dire ce qui s'était passé
au sein d'un parti politique
il faut faire en sorte maintenant qu' il
ya des cadres partout qui puisse exister
pour que les femmes se sentent les
tim a parlé n'ai pas peur de parler donc
il faut légiférer
je pense surtout qu'il faut faire en
sorte que des référents qui doivent par
la loi existait dans les entreprises
soit vraiment mis en place si vous avez
peur de perdre votre emploi parce que
vous parlez alors que vous subissez du
harcèlement sexuel bien vous ne parlerez
jamais et donc il faut encore une fois
qu'on vérifie que le cadre est bien
appliquée on arrive à la fin de cette
émission une toute dernière question
savoir que le regard que vous auriez
aujourd'hui si vous aviez c'est zorro
justement et que vous deviez vous lancer
en politique
énormément changé un style de vous
engageriez de la même manière je
m'engagerai ça c'est certain parce que
ça fait partie de mon caractère mon adn
on peut donc oui je m'engagerai et c'est
vrai que je pense que la dynamique créée
par une aile makuch le ce qu'il est en
train de réaliser par exemple sur le
plan européen ce qu'on est en train de
faire pour l'école c'est quelque chose
qui est très enthousiasmant on vit quand
même un moment politique qui à la fois
on a eu l'impression pendant toute la
campagne présidentielle d'être sur le
fil est-ce qu'on va basculer d'un côté
qui est optimiste qui était justement la
candidature de maquereau ou est ce que
la france va se replier sur l'extrême
droite sur le front national on a choisi
l'optimisme
donc ça ça mérite qu'on continue à
s'engager merci or verger carrière ce
café politique
[Musique]